que j'ai quand même des noms jusque là
dans les films ce chic où on pourrait
donner à son enfant quoi enfin bénédicte
intérêts passion d'enfant benedetta mais
sybille que j'ai victoria et la suze
quoi s'appelle suze sus trapèze un
programme en soi très concrètement sur
démarre sur des éléments biographiques
c'est une femme qui a
quinze ans est enceinte une histoire
d'amour
ses parents l'ont obligé à abandonner
l'enfant après il ya une fêlure koala en
disant qu'on n'a pas bien démarré dans
l'existence et des coiffeuses s'est elle
a cherché à revoir à retrouver son
enfant mais ç'a toujours été extrêmement
complexe et au moment où démarre le film
elle va elle apprend qu'elle a une
maladie
là elle doit absolument retrouver son
enfant c'est une femme d'une grande
sensibilité qui vous avez que cette
chose très particulière de savoir
qu'elle n'en a plus pour longtemps et
qu'il ya des urgences
il ya une urgence pour elle c'est de
retrouver son enfant et elle est prête à
tout d'un coup tu te rends compte que
c'est plus technique mois normalement
jamais assez bien j'ai et j'ai eu ça
avec les différents metteurs en scène
avec qui j'ai travaillé
une possibilité de ne jamais devoir bien
faire c'était super c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas une finalité
tout à fait choisi déjà sur comment la
phrase doit résonner comment l'émotion
doit être perçue donc et un bagage on a
travaillé sur il ya toute une idée de
réalisation et après ça tu appartiens et
et finalement il n'y a pas de bons
mauvais chemin et tu peux toi même du
coup ne pas tout contrôler et donc à une
part de choses qui qui s'échappe et tu
ne sais jamais bien quel est le chemin
que tu vas prendre même si effectivement
il ya des endroits où il ya des balises
et là albert était que c'est quelqu'un
qui est extrêmement fort dans le
contrôle qui a pensé son film en long en
large en travers dans tous les sens et
qu'une science des plans etc
il va et obsessionnel il va chercher
plus loin que les autres
donc il ne faut pas déranger cette
mécanique et puis on fait des
répétitions et dans les répétitions je
dis waouh quel est très précis quoi donc
c'est à dire quand j'ai cette phrase
visage à droite la phrase là non plus au
nom plus bas ok moi je trouve que c'est
intéressant déjà des gens qui savent
comment ils veulent faire des choses et
je t'adore l'idée de l'adaptation
quant au rédacteur de 10 mais toi tu
préfère faire beaucoup de prises est
prise je n'en sais rien c'est de ces
c'est quelque chose qui se joue avec le
metteur en scène tout le temps mais la
seule crainte de sade cette grande
technique c'est une fois que tu es sur
le plateau comment pas devenir un
un corps mort quoi c'est à dire bien
dire ça bien dire ça et que cette chose
qui ait pu avoir une fluidité et ça en
fait du kunar lâché j'ai même vu que des
choses qu'on avait répété à fond ce
manière de dire en fait je pouvais le
dire autrement
mais du coup j'avais ce bagage technique
et puis sur le plateau il est aussi
particulier parce que normalement les
metteurs en scène n'aime pas que les
acteurs à y voir
le combo lisent les images parce qu'ils
ont peur qu'on se regarde nous mêmes et
qu'on dise non l'amant double menton non
facebook je sais pas quoi d'ailleurs
moi j'aime assez bien cet instrument là
parce que ça permet de voir une image on
appartient une image et parfois tu fais
tu dans une scène tu peux te sentir
l'émotion qui vient et qui passe par
plein de choses et tout est croire qu'à
cet endroit là c'était super c'est
peut-être pas l'endroit le mieux est
parfois c'est juste effectivement un
cadrage et voir les images te permet de
comprendre ça et lui tu tournes alors
qu'il est un parterre de jeu tu as même
pas finie la scène qui est déjà là au
combo en train de regarder que tu vas
voir avec l'unodc et la tête la plus
drôle de machin plus truc auquel on y
retourne comme un truc d'apnéistes qui
va prendre des informations